drunk history returns to Comedy Central
next Tuesday at 10:00 p.m. Eastern Time
the fifth season of drunk history in the
creator Derek waters big Baltimore
sports fan sitting right next to me here
on the Rich Eisen show good to see you
sir to see you sir so how in the world
did you come up with the concept of of
drunk history how did it start well
drinking definitely involved drinking
yes a night of drinking
I was with my dear friend Jake Johnson
he's a great actor and here's a big
Harris family huge Bears fan him and I
were some unemployed actors having an
unemployed night of drinking beer and
talking about music and Jake was trying
so hard to convince me that Otis Redding
knew he was gonna die before he got on
that plane that unfortunately crashed
and he was just like Derek I'm serious
man he looked at his wife and he was
like you take care of yourself Otis has
got to go and his wife was like I will
notice you take care of yourself he's
like no I gotta go you know what I mean
I went to leave and I was just like
there's no way this happened I just kept
picturing and Otis Redding moving his
lips to what Jake was saying but also
like shaking his head looking at me and
saying no I was like oh maybe it did
happen what's something we can do the
same joke on so I was like oh what if
it's a moment in history that you can
know what's right what's wrong but the
person just is convinced that tell you
that it's the truth so now the follow-up
question sure do the people who narrate
history drunk are they actually drinking
yeah getting drunk it breaks my heart
that I hope you can tell they're real
because I would be a hack if they
weren't cuz the only thing worse about
being around a drunk person is being
around someone pretending to be drunk
that is the worst but yes they are a
hundred percent drunk
everyone's intoxication level is
different but there's something that I
I'm not Pro alcohol but I'm Pro comedy
and pro history sure and when you have a
couple drinks over you are so passionate
and that's what I find like my favorite
part of the show or anything really is
when someone is convincing you no matter
what this is the way it happened and
just committing to their idea and taking
it okay serious as possible so wit
of the many mmm hilarious stars and
serious actor stars that you had on the
show
which one is handled the alcohol worse
mmm I'm gonna throw someone under the
bus I'm not good or that so you don't to
throw anybody under the bus
maybe me once so I'll throw myself okay
a one time I couldn't see I remember
that I'm on you know I lost vision for a
second but I was trying to compete with
Dan Harmon so you learned a lot you know
okay sometimes you learn history
sometimes you learn okay about yourself
all right
but yeah everyone has a different law so
then who's handled their alcohol the
best then was the one cuz I have to do
it every time okay
but yeah yeah they're all winners in my
bud okay and so do do the celebrities
choose which I would say what's a moment
or the drink I say what's a drink that
you've never gotten sick on you know no
one says Mad Dog 2020 not to date myself
but and then the moments a history we
have a research team and then I give the
narrators the stories and then they have
about two weeks to learn it and then get
drunk and tell but all the stories are a
hundred percent true so this is well
researched it's well researched because
that it would be it'll be too lazy to
make a show where you're just making up
stories these are real my dream was
somebody watching the show me like
they're so drunk oh wait I just learned
something and it's all real the
dialogues off the facts the facts are
real yeah I couldn't tell that the
dialogue was off by Tiffany Haddish is
recounting of something then yeah one of
the time Derek waters creator of Comedy
Central's drunk history season five
premieres Tuesday January 23rd at 10
p.m. Eastern and Pacific which have you
done a sports one we did yeah one season
two we did a man it's been so long we
did are you drunk now no you know but
that always happens to me because I was
born like this you know I didn't know
when God said which voice you want and
which face I wouldn't have picked these
you know but I've always talked slow
when it looked slow okay and people I
remember when I first moved out here I
was at a bar and I was waiting for a
friend and I said oh can I get a miller
lite I'm not advertising and she said oh
we only have Mexican beer and I didn't
know what that really meant at the time
when I'll say oh I guess I love a Corona
take the Corona I sip it and the bouncer
just throws me out
I said what are you doing he's like my
boss said you've been drinking too much
and I was like this is all I've had I
just got here and she's like that
doesn't mean you haven't been
bar-hopping buddy why don't you sober up
and I said this is my voice the only
time it worked really quick was one time
I got pulled over trying and I was with
some friends from Baltimore they were
visiting and the Caguas gonna help you
and I said yeah oh we're just trying to
find the bowling alley where they shot
the Big Lebowski in and he's like how
many drinks have you had
and I said none this is how I talk and
he goes you know what actually believe
you have a good night Wow that's in
Crimea so which was the sporting event
this or two of the sports one you know
okay we did Jim Abbott which was really
cool because rarely we tell stories
about people that are still alive but
being able to there's so many people
don't know about Jim Abbott
who was the one who recounted drunkenly
the Matt Jones he's here on Friday yeah
yeah told a great story I believe he was
sober when he told her about Jay Cutler
at a urinal once
oh really thing a fan yes that chose the
inopportune time to address Jay Cutler
and what a big fan he was of Jay you
shouldn't do that I don't like when you
hear stories like no I'm not gonna sign
but when you're going the bathroom I
agree
no I absolutely grad I absolutely agree
that and eating and certainly if you're
eating while peeing right that's I
always do that so what do you have this
season what's the drunk history that you
do this season well this season well
that one was heroines our season
premieres about heroines and
I'm very excited with that we also did
one you know after five seasons you want
to do stuff that sort of breaks the
rules and so I was obsessed with
unsolved mysteries as a kid okay so we
made an episode called drunk mystery
where I'm Robert Stack lip synching to
this amazing not sound-alike Robert
Stack and we do all right okay mysteries
and yeah it's fun it's a brand-new
season I can't believe it's been five
five years yeah well it started ten
years ago so it's it's a lot what would
be a problem what would be a good sports
idea let's let's let's do this by the
way tequila for me is a night ender
really immediately and nothing good ever
came out of the queue I cannot hand
tequila for me when I don't understand
people like them they start hey let's do
a shot of tequila I'm like that it's
first of all it's six o'clock reckoned
ly if I want to see 6:05 I can't do this
yeah it really is a night under for me
so what do you what do you think would
be this has it has to it has to be so
long ago the people aren't alive any no
no no I come as long as there's an
ending what about the Immaculate
reception yeah that's a good one I was
thinking like that would be good sports
drunk history Bobby Thompson the shot
heard round the world
oh yeah Giants win the pennant yeah I
would love Vikings this weekend would be
a good between the leg oh the Bill
Buckner but he has to get drunk and tell
the story so I don't know if we could
work on that Larry David got him to make
fun of that whole situation yeah and
apparently he had to personally lobby
him quite a bit for that to happen so I
don't know about having him to do how
about Jeffrey Mayer catching the ball
against your Orioles I mean I hate the
Yankees but yeah I would do that but Joe
Namath predicting the shortest trinket
is it how a person actually drinking
resist no no I could get drunken drunken
tell that story if you would be up for
it I just wouldn't let you murder he was
there Mossberg are getting half on drunk
history now that I think we just struck
upon a winner but I there is that as a
matter of fact was Brent drunk when he
called into our chef
[Laughter]
we just laughing like that that wouldn't
be a bad one the Buckner play or Jeffrey
Mayer yeah Heartbreakers so how long
does it take to get these people drunk
it's about six to eight hours is you
know you learn you learn that anybody in
front of a camera with alcohol is gonna
try to be funny so you just let that go
for the first hour okay and then we you
know hang out a little more have a cup
and they tell it a bunch of times it's a
science it's well it's working out great
man and the names that you're getting in
it's so much it's so much fun so
congrats on that come back anytime
absolutely fifth season again fifth
season of drunk history premieres
Tuesday at 10:00 p.m. Eastern next week
on Comedy Central the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience